welcome to the pi data global conference
today we're going to be taking a look at
aiqc an open source library that enables
researchers to adopt rapid rigorous and
reproducible deep learning into their
work to push science forward it handles
all of the pre-processing of data the
tracking of experiments automatically
scores and produces charts for every
single model fold hyper parameter
combination that's run and then also
handles inference essentially it's open
source ml ops
my name is lane sadler i'm the creator
of the library and most recently
director of product management at julia
computing a bit about the project itself
it just received a nod from the python
software foundation in the form of a
grant from the scientific working group
in order to introduce support for time
series pre-processing and analysis into
the library so if you want to check out
the source code it's out there on github
and
all of the examples the different types
of analysis and data pipelines that are
supported are in notebook format on read
the docs so it's extremely easy to
follow along with and if you prefer to
just jump on in then it's a pip install
with a one-liner to set up the database
so that you can start tracking your
experiments
so we're going to begin our description
of the problems that aiqc aims to solve
with a bit of a thought experiment
looking at a traditional machine
learning training exercise imagine that
we've split our data into training data
and we're feeding into our model and
then evaluating it on the test data
so we're seeing an accuracy of 88 on the
training data and the test data is not
quite performing so well so we're going
to make some changes to our model our
parameters and architecture
and
we see that both improve the training is
pretty much done
but we're going to continue
using what we've learned to
influence our model we're going to
push it we're going to change our
parameters in our architecture and we
see that finally our test data is
done right and this point and simple is
evaluation bias we've effectively used
our entire data set
to
influence the model and you might be
thinking to yourself no we we only use
the training data that's all we revealed
to the model but there's actually a
second neural network in play here
and it's not artificial it's
biological
right it's us
we
as practitioners
are
seeing how our model performs
on the test data the holdout data and
we're making changes to our model
based on that
repeatedly so
we're using all of the data
to change our parameters and that's
where evaluation bias comes from i
learned this from the fast fastai
o'reilly book i can't take credit for it
but it really got me to think about
validation splits and how important they
are
okay so we're sold on validation splits
now how do we actually
implement them
based on what i saw maybe the apis have
changed i couldn't find an easy way most
things were still designed around the
original train test split
and if you wanted to introduce your own
validation split you had to just split
again had implications for
stratification but
this kind of involved math and i thought
that sounds like something a framework
could solve another area where
leakage can occur with respect to your
holdout and validation splits is
encoding so
let's say that you have decided to
encode on your entire data set and maybe
you're just taking something simple like
an average if you have high values in
your test and validation data that's
going to influence your encoder it's
going to influence your average
so this is a form of data leakage
and what you're supposed to do is fit on
your training data and then transform or
encode each split or fold separately and
this
folding becomes
pretty impractical by hand when you
consider that
you've got this rotating validation
split and you need to encode each
differently it's pretty infeasible
so
here's an example of encoding right you
know we've got planet a categorical
distance to the sun
call it an integer continuous
and then is gaseous right boolean and
we're going to apply different encoders
to those right so if we run hot in code
standard scale and binarize our features
then
we're left with pretty
unhuman readable
features and when it comes time to do
metrics to compare to the original data
or produce human readable charts or do
comparisons of models or inference
actual predictions you better hope that
you saved those encoders so that you can
actually
decode your data to make it human
readable and you have to do this for
every single model which is equal to the
number of hyper parameter combinations
you have times the you know one for
splits and then many for folds so
there's a lot to keep track of a lot of
moving pieces
additionally this post-processing
process varies based on the type of
analysis that you're conducting so as
you can see here i've got a confusion
matrix on the screen
and
it has different splits associated with
it as it should but you wouldn't do that
chart for a regression analysis right
you're going to have different types of
metrics and charts
based on the analysis that you're
conducting and that's kind of hard to
pick up on if you're someone new to the
space it sounds like something for a
framework to solve
additionally pre-processing
aside from just you know the type of
analysis we want to conduct there's
different data types there's many
different types of dimensions right like
you could analyze data over time then
you have one sample
for a single subject over time and then
modality introduces multiple features
for a given sample so
tabular data is easy it's just a table
then sequence data over time you start
to have multiple tables and then image
data is you know channels and there's
just many different tables that you need
to know how to coordinate how to encode
how to decode and how to
jam into your training model so again
sounds like a good problem for a
framework to solve here's an example of
sliding windows so
when you're doing forecasting you want
to look forward into the future and then
you have to treat each slide as a sample
and if you're doing multivariate feature
encoding it's pretty much impossible to
do by hand so you need a framework for
that problem thank you to the python
software foundation
so
models themselves they're really only
made to be run with a snapshot of the
parameters that they have they're not
designed to be fed up you know soup of
hyper parameters and different
architectures
so
if you have different hyper parameters
that you want to feed in that's pretty
easy in aiqc and it's going to tell you
based on all the different models that
you have
as a multi-model framework
how they're performing right so each dot
you see here is training validation test
so i can very easily pick out the models
that are performing consistently and are
going to generalize well based on
different metrics on my choosing based
on the type of analysis that was
conducted so to summarize the problems
that aiqc aims to solve i looked for
experiment trackers that would kind of
fit the bill and solve these problems
but i found them
inadequate or commercial
i didn't want to do command line stuff i
was working with all these different
python libraries i just wanted something
that would integrate directly with them
and i didn't want it to
run alongside and kind of like keep
track of things i wanted to structure
the analysis i wanted to run multiple
models using my hyper parameters and i
wanted those different models to know
which split and or fold to use and i
wanted the charts automatically done for
me i didn't want to make them myself
additionally when i started to design
the architecture of this application i
said
my user doesn't know how to configure a
database and they don't want to manage
that they don't want to be running more
command line stuff i'll just handle all
the database interaction for them right
and
it needs to handle inference too it's
not enough just to track it and then
you've got this model it's
when you're training the model and you
you're encoding the data that's where
the fit happens you need to save that
fit so that you can decode predictions
during inference and i didn't want to
yeah cloud sas was a no-go
um
so a lot of the most manual part of this
that i was able to automate
is the post-processing that's respective
to the type of analysis being conducted
the the decoding
calculating the performance metrics
doing the different charts based on the
type of analysis and then finally
comparing all the different models in
one place and i didn't want to have to
manually do all of that again during
inference right because you know what's
the point if you're already doing it
during evaluation
and i think a key point that
um you know scientists why this is
called qc is it's quality control right
it's a rigorous well-defined protocol
that researchers can follow and when
you're learning deep learning
you're just kind of scrounging through
online blogs and trying to piece
together bits of documentation to figure
out am i actually am i doing this right
and that's not how science works you're
supposed to have a very rigorous
protocol and you're supposed to know
what you're doing and aiqc provides
bumper rails that help with that it
doesn't talk about machine learning in
terms of x and y and math it talks about
things that we understand
features and labels these are these are
objects and we should treat them as such
in their absence as such
so a scientist isn't a data scientist
necessarily
right
they might know some of the pieces and
how to put them together and how to
structure experiments but
they're fundamentally not programmers
and all of the stuff that i'm describing
requires a lot of manual programming
because it's not these these frameworks
aren't finished deep learning is in its
infancy machine learning is in its
infancy still we're so far to go when
you look at differentiable programming
now
we describe some of the different ways
that data leakage of our holdout can
occur right and you can solve this by
doing validation splits but if your
framework doesn't support validation
switch that's a major problem what if
you want to use validation switz with
crossfolds and you want to
fit uniquely on you don't want to fit
your validation fold right
that's a problem that aiqc solves
how do you save your encoders we've
talked about that and then actually you
know what sample ids did i actually use
if you can't answer that that's
something you would want to answer in a
sixth grade science experiment we should
be able to say i trained my model on
these samples so if you want to question
me about bias have at it and then
pre-processing tools
this is extremely painful they're really
designed for 2d data sometimes 1d data
which is even more painful than
3d data so how do i encode even in 2d
data how do i encode different columns
and d types uniquely right so
you need to slice out each
query that fits and then encode them and
then concatenate them all back together
in the end it's really challenging in 2d
data and then it's worse than 5d data
so
when you start to work with time series
data and image data that's where things
go off the rails because you're finding
yourself coordinating all of this
encoding and decoding the decodings even
worse because you have to reverse
engineer it instead of just engineering
it
you have to say this data was encoded
how do i decode it
so those are the problems that can make
deep learning
challenging make the make your head spin
and i thought you know can i design a
framework that's easy that is object
oriented that
solves all of this with high level apis
for
new practitioners and low-level apis for
people that really want to jump in and
customize things
and i believe i've struck that balance
with aiqc it's a python package that you
can download
you ingest your data using different
data types tabular sequence image
supports in memory formats as well as
file based formats to ingest your data
you can perform unbiased pre-processing
on different types of data by encoding
uniquely on your splits and or folds it
handles stratification in all the you
know different areas that normal
libraries don't support stratification
and
it allows you to keep track of every
single sample that's going into a split
and or fold
then comes time for tuning you define
your hyper parameters in python and
you treat each component of the model
you know training
loss
um
building the model itself the optimizer
as a different component and a function
so that you can pass parameters into
them that you define not only values but
also architectures so it's extremely
flexible in structuring the analysis it
actually makes it more flexible and then
those jobs know what data they're
supposed to talk to because that's all
coordinated in the back end through the
api
and
the
my favorite part is that
as soon as you click run you're you're
pretty much done because all the metrics
are going to be laid out for you based
on the type of analysis that you
conducted it says classification
regression it also supports unsupervised
which is actually really just kind of a
type of regression and then you can do
all of this again during inference
it's entirely reproducible because it's
recorded all the steps that you've
chosen are recorded in the database
that's automatically set up when you run
aiqc dot setup
so end to end your workflow is
reproducible
all right demo time so whenever i
install aiqc i'm pretty certain it's
going to work because all it needs is
access to a python3 shell and any
operating system it doesn't matter if
it's mac
windows wsl or a different distribution
of linux it's pretty long level
um all it needs to do is create a sqlite
file and that's what
aiqc.setup is and if you want to see
where that lives it's using actors to
write it to a proper
directory um
which is essentially like the new home
directory actors right so here you can
see the sql knight file and aiqc is
going to act as an orm between that
database and your experiments for the
purpose of persistence and
reproducibility there's a ton of dummy
data baked in for testing many different
types of analysis that the framework
supports
here you can see i've imported the iris
data set my favorite it's what i learned
on we've got a label column of species
that's a categorical type object and
then we've got many different feature
columns
that are floats right so now we're going
to begin to prepare the data this is
where the magic starts to happen right
my favorite part of this framework is
actually the pre-processing not the
experiment tracking so it supports
different types of data tabular sequence
and image you can use in memory file
formats
in memory or file formats right so here
i'm just going to run with the data
frame and i'm not going to change any of
the d types for the labels i'm going to
take that species column i'm not going
to it's not a time series status i'm not
going to do any interpolation and i'm
going to say let's one hot encode those
labels i left this blank because i just
overwrite any defaults that won't work
the feature pre-processing i'm going to
leave out
you can include or exclude columns so
i'm going to leave out species columns
and work with all those float columns
again it's not time series status we
don't need to worry about this and then
we're going to do multiple types of
encoders just for fun so we'll take that
um first column here we'll apply one
encoder to it and then the remaining
floats will apply standard scalar to it
and then this isn't a crazy
dimensionality problem we don't need any
reshaping we're not going to do any
cross folding and we are going to
introduce a validation split
and a test split and
because this isn't a regression problem
we don't need to worry about stratifying
our bins
but yeah it's uh this is the high level
api there's a low level api if you want
to go in here and tweak even more stuff
now we get to design our experiments so
there's different functions build train
and down here you can see law lose
optimize predict
these are the different components of a
model right so
we've got a pretty basic keras
sequential model here and you can see
i've got different arguments that are
predefined and this is all in the
documentation but we make it easy for
you by helping you identify what the
shape of your features are you just
call it and then we pass in the hyper
parameters that you
define below
so again for based on type of analysis
you've defined you've got different
arguments that are going to be passed in
and
the samples are pre-processed for you so
we might as well just hand those off to
you right
now
the hyper parameters
are pretty neat because they can be
values or they can just be conditionals
right so i could say like if fourth
layer is true run and then i can have
true and false as a hyper parameter and
then run
different architectures just by tweaking
that simple boolean right
now we pass these things into the
experiment this is the second object of
the high level api right so
uh
split set is not defined so i must have
not run this cell here
my bad
and as you can see it tests the encoders
that we've defined and sequentially so
it says hey sepal length that was the
first one the remaining columns that you
have that you can encode are these great
so
now i'm going to say i'm going to work
with that
you know that d type here and grab all
those and encode that next that's how
that sequential encoding works right so
now i'm going to go ahead and
instantiate that q object that doesn't
do anything it just gets the queue ready
so within here we're saying keras you
can do old school
tensorflow if you want
it also supports pi torch again that's
all in the documentation
this is a classification multi-problem
that has implications for
our labels it has implications for the
types of metrics that we want to
render the framework handles all of that
for us we pass in our build and train
function we leave these buddies blank
you can customize them if you want and i
plan to
and then you just take those hyper
parameters we defined up here just drag
and drop them into the experiment
i
grid search feels a little
um much so i'm just going to take 66 of
the combinations of these hyper
parameters
and there's different strategies that
you can apply here you point it at that
split set as the source of data
and you don't need a fold set you need
both because
a test split is not in a fold set and
then i'm only going to repeat this once
because this is a non-deterministic
process you could repeat it three times
if you wanted to
and it's going to give you a different
result each time and then hide test is
set to
false
so
we've staged that multiple times now and
i'm now going to go ahead and run it
and what this is going to do is it's
just going to cue up those models and
then execute them one by one and
what we're going to see is that it's
automatically
calculating the performance metrics and
charts for all of those so all we have
to do is focus on
the architecture that we want to run
that's really the beauty of it is you
just focus on the pre-processing it's
all about revealing the right data to
the right architecture and then voila it
should just work that's what artificial
intelligence is about
so this is the boomerang chart it shows
you all the models that you trained
looks like we've got
some interesting ones here and here you
can see this orange guy right so i've
got my train split i've got my test
split and validation switch and they're
all above 96 percent and they're pretty
consistent this one's a little lossy the
validation but it's only 18 so i'll let
that slide
and then if i
want to see you know a specific model i
can dive into
um the learning curve of it
and that's interactive again
uh all the classification metrics are
ready to go so if you want to take a
look at your rock curve and see
what's really going on
uh classification uh
confusion matrices are done for every
single split and or folds so you can you
can see exactly what's going on so you
can see oh here like my actual label is
versacolor but this classified it as
virginica
that's nice to have especially in
medical scenarios
precision recall and then finally just
to cap it all off um google collab isn't
great with pandas
so
here are for every single model every
single split you've got all the metrics
if you want to manually inspect them
thank you for tuning in to this talk
about aiqc if you are a researcher i
hope this makes it easy for you to
integrate deep learning into your
research
when i think about the future of aiqc
it's twofold one taking things to the
clouds that models can be parallelized
and
shared persisted for collaborative
purposes and you know reproducibility
purposes
uh two adding support for different
types of analyses not mentioned here
near and dear to my heart are graft
neural networks and generative
adversarial networks aiqc is well
positioned to handle gans and treat them
kind of as branches so you can get good
results quickly
and
last but not least i want to say thank
you to
pi data for hosting this conference and
inviting me to give a talk so
thank you very much
you